so how do you get rid of post acne marks
and acne scars? in this video I'm gonna
share with you eight tips to do just
that
hi I'm Daniel and welcome to DLM model
lifestyle. now if you're new to my
channel subscribe click the notification
bell so you won't miss any of the next
videos
now pimples and acne will go away with
time but the scars and the marks that
they leave behind afterwards: they're a
little bit more tougher to deal with. so
how long does it take for the post acne
marks to go away? well everybody's skin
is different right and so with the right
and consistent treatment over a period
of two to three months you should start
to see some good results, but it also
depends on how fresh the marks or the
scars are, your ability to heal and also
how deep the scars or the marks are. so
the truth is it will take some
consistency and time. so you have to be
patient. so with that in mind let's start
with the first tip to get rid of acne
marks and scars
as you probably already know most skin
care products and home remedies they
don't always work as you hope that they
would but if you know what ingredients
to look for in the products it will help
you out a lot. now research shows that a
trio of a non irritating cleanser,
salicylic acid exfoliant and an anti
acne product containing benzoyl peroxide
can dramatically improve and transform
a blemish prone complexion and also Minimize
the look of post acne marks. also
you can focus on products with loads of
antioxidants vitamin C and also skin
restoring ingredients like retinol now
if you're not sure which products to use
I'll add the links of my personal best
options for you in a video description
down below just so it's a bit easier for
you to go and check them out and do your
own research. just so you know I'll add
also the links of all the other products
that I'm going to talk about in this
video down below for you
there's loads of videos out there with
home remedies that are just not true so
let's talk about home remedies there's a
lot of mixed opinions about it and some
people think that they work and some
people believe that they don't work but
let's talk about the post acne marks
first and then we'll talk about the
scars now I personally believe that
at-home post acne mark remedies such as
rubbing lemon juice or any other kind of
fruits on your face do not work. why?
because they cannot exfoliate the skin
properly and they're acidic juices are
strong skin sensitizers that can cause
post acne marks to last even longer so
that's a lot worse and you don't want
that. the only thing that I might try is
aloe vera but you can look into that. now
let's take a look at that acne scars and
home remedies now scars are permanent
indentations due to damage of collagen
in your skin and to be honest the scars
are very hard to deal with unless you do
chemical peels and lasers but I will
talk about that a little bit later now
there are a few things that you can use
on your scars to make them look a little
bit better and they are manuka, helichrysum
frankincense, vetiver, aloe vera,
shea butter, coconut oil, onion extract
and apple cider vinegar
now I know that this might be difficult
for some of you but you have to try and
stop touching picking at and just
popping those pimples and blemishes just
try to leave them alone. I remember I had
this photo shoot and I walked in to the
makeup room and the makeup artist was
sitting in front of the mirror and she
was just going at them in a rough way,
never do it in public, anyway I just
thought at that moment Shh she's gonna
touch my face with her fingers that just
touched all of her pimples, so I had to go
and talk with her and say hey please
just go and wash your hands and anyway
I'm talking about other stuff now let's
get back to the video. if you pick at
your pimples then it can cause a lot
more scarring and it will damage your
skin and that's not what you want. now I
know sometimes you do have to pop a
pimple,  especially if
you have a very important event but
there is a safe way to do it. maybe I'll
make a video about that later now if you
have severe blemishes you know those
that are kind of inflamed and red and
they just look very big those ones
they're very likely to scar if you pick
at them so try not to. now let's continue
to the next tip
now let's talk about abrasive scrubs now
there's a lot of people out there that
says scrubs can help with post acne
marks but can it really? breakouts and
acne marks can generally not be scrubbed
away, it will just probably make things a
lot worse. if you use abrasive scrubs
over the pimples and acne marks and
breakouts then it's just gonna aggravate
that skin even more causing micro-tears
which will make those acne marks even
harder to get rid of and that's just gonna
delay bringing your skin back to normal
again try to wear sunscreen every day
why? well because unprotected exposure to
UV light steadily damages your skin. now what does that mean?
that means those kind
of red spots from the post acne marks
will stick around longer so if you
protect your skin from the Sun it will
diminish the look of post acne marks
now let's talk about prevention now most
people get shocked when they start to
get a lot of pimples and then the scars
come and then it's too late
so you want to stop them right at the
beginning, so take good care of your skin
to prevent pimples and acne from
appearing in the first place because if
you stop them right at the beginning
they cannot cause any post acne marks or
scars. so use a good skin care routine to
help you prevent acne and pimples. now if
you're not sure which products to use
again I'll add my best options for you
in a video description down below let's
go to the next tip
PMD now what does PMD means?
well it basically stands for personal
microderm system now this is basically
like a microdermabrasion treatment that
you can do at home. so what does it do?
well, weekly treatments reduces the fine
lines, wrinkles, blemishes and enlarged
pores but there's a lot of people out
there that use it for the post acne
marks and especially the scars. now just
so you know I have never personally used
this myself but I've read a lot of
customer reviews and I did a lot of
research on this and most people are
very very happy with the results. again
I'll add a link for you so you can read
the customer reviews for yourself and do
a bit of research. now most people
experience that it kind of smoothed out
and softened the post acne scars
and most of the discoloration also faded
all right now lastly if you have very
bad acne scars or post acne marks
and it is at such a level where it
really brings down your confidence and
you've tried most of these tips that
I've mentioned already, try to go and see
a dermatologist because they know what
they're talking about. they're probably
gonna recommend chemical peels or lasers
and that is probably the best option but
a lot of people are scared or not
scared, they're hesitant to go
and see a dermatologist. I'm not sure
why... maybe because a lot of people think
that it's too expensive. I don't know but
just go and hear them out see the
options let them look at your face
alright and after you hear the options
you can decide what options to take or
you can just go home as well
alright now just a reminder if you
missed my videos on how to stop or how
to prevent acne and pimples go and check
that video out I'll link it for you
right here that's it guys if you liked
it subscribe click the notification bell
and that's it Cheers